una circunstancia que vivimos aquí en
méxico pues es la necesidad de salir
adelante todos somos bien echados para
adelante estudiamos una carrera
iniciamos algún negocio tomamos algún
camino y algún consejo que creemos que
nos va a ayudar y eso prácticamente se
llama esperanza la esperanza es la que
nos hace tener una pequeña certidumbre
de que el día de mañana va a ser mejor
que hoy así yo me fui moviendo en la
vida tratando de ver la manera en la que
podía construir un mejor méxico como
muchos de ustedes y muchos chavos que
quieren ver un méxico distinto méxico
con más tecnología con más avances con
aportes para todos yo me movía y
obviamente primero lo primero que podía
hacer porque yo estudié licenciada en
derecho pues la primera carrera que tuve
era arreglarle papelitos a las señoras
no que tenía algún problema en su
colonia y ahí me fui moviendo y dije
mira puedo hacer cada vez pueda ser
mayor magnitud y fuimos construyendo
casas al punto de que en alguna vez
logramos incluso establecer un hospital
después yo me di cuenta que aparte de
pedirle ayuda a todas las personas a mi
alrededor para ver qué podíamos hacer
también yo necesitaba tener mis propios
recursos para poder hacer algunos
proyectos
como mucho corazón por lograr por ver
cristalizados algún día a partir de ahí
me dedico a los negocios e imagínense si
sin dinero podríamos hacer un hospital
pues a ver imagínense con dinero y la
iniciativa privada es todo lo que pasaba
todo lo que podíamos comenzar hasta de
nuevo logró cosas allá en el norte y
cuando ya me sentía lo suficientemente
cristalizado y cristalizado me refiero a
que ya había dado golpes había tenido
deudas había tenido créditos que tenía
que pagar de un sinfín de maneras que me
las arreglé y que de alguna manera
llegaba a la semana y tenía los 30.000 y
los 40.000 los invitados para pagar en
esa semana y se empezaba a componer la
la vida pues dije creo que ahora sí ya
pone un granito en mi estado ya pudiera
poner un granito a michoacán me vengo
para acá y sorprendentemente en la
primera semana que estuve aquí me
invitan a dar una conferencia para
pueblitos de diferentes comunidades
accedo a uno de un amigo de la
universidad y me dice oye puede venir a
darnos una conferencia de emprendimiento
con todo esto que viene haciendo
legisladores y yo llegué ahí y yo llegué
con acá sentimiento de charlatán que yo
llegué de que voy haga realidad
a meter dinero a la edad de ese chavo
porque prácticamente yo no tenía
conocimiento de lo que pasaba en
michoacán no tenía muchos contactos por
aquí todavía y me faltaban también
conocer un poquito de los negocios que
se pueden hacer yo fui de la conferencia
al final muchos hábitos se me acercaron
y me dieron sus hojitas no de los
negocios que ellos habían preparado para
presentarme como cualquier chavo de esa
edad sabe de 15 años 18 años pues
realmente tus negocios poquito
infantiles le falta la mejor un poquito
más de un modelo de negocio más
establecido pero lo importante fue que
lo intentaron y sobre todo se
mantuvieron en contacto conmigo para ver
qué podemos hacer y adónde podíamos
llegar
pero de estos chavos había uno que por
el tenor de la historia voy a cambiar su
nombre que ojalá les pueda presentar
algún día y yo estoy seguro que va a
estar aquí dando una en algún momento y
luego de gabriel el show que abriese más
cerca de 18 años si me dices una vez que
tengo esta idea de negocio y tengo un
problema mi papá se la ha pasado ganando
mil quinientos euros por semana durante
toda su vida y con eso ha hecho la
pequeña casita que tenemos
y con eso he educado a las cuatro
personas el mantiene aquí en nuestra
casa ya mí yo dije ahí está que está
canijo porque obviamente cuando era
estudiante y cuando era universitario
con 500 pesos 400 pesos de asia para la
semana estando donde fuera pero cuando
ya estás en la vida real y te toca en la
responsabilidad te das cuenta de que se
ocupa de dinero y ocupa dinero para
salir adelante y para poder apoyar a las
personas que tú más quieres
el chavo yo lo vi con los ojos con esa
con ese valor con el sentimiento de
querer cambiar a su familia de querer
darle mejores oportunidades y además
venía con una hojita que había escrito
ahí con lápiz y donde me propuso un
modelo de negocio bien interesante para
la industria manufactura y logística del
país por también por tenor de la plática
no puedo decir el giro del negocio pero
sólo les quiero decir que tenía que ver
con el bajío
entonces empezamos a hacer todo el
modelo me gustó muchísimo la final
algunas cosas y le dije sabes que yo te
meta el dinero y te meto con los
contactos que ocupes a este negocio él
me dijo listo hecho lo hacemos el día de
mañana no sé yo me quedé toda la tarde
platicando y en un parte militar de la
zona del panel porque la zona pues
obviamente era una zona comunitaria
entonces los pocos lugares que están
bien positivos eran del ejército
mexicano no porque estuviera inseguro de
hecho en ese momento era un lugar muy
seguro de michoacán hablábamos y todo y
al día siguiente recibo precisamente una
llamada donde el mismo chavo me decía
negocio porque es muy buena idea y
prefiero hacerlo con mi familia
a los 3 meses me llamen me dice no mi
familia nueva apoyar que me dijo que soy
un chavo de 19 años y que voy a andar
haciendo en los negocios entre él y
ahora le pues yo si dentro de todos
maría yo estaba esperando la oportunidad
pero no me quiera robar la edad la
verdad porque era un emprendedor lo que
le duele mucho y lo marca es cuando tú
ves que otra persona se apropia un
proyecto el parto le presentaste llámese
lo que sea
puedes hacerlo entonces dije me late ya
vi como la manera amable y saludable de
empezado con este chavo le empezamos a
meter dinero habló con su papá se meten
de lleno al negocio imagínense la
responsabilidad que yo tenía por qué el
señor renuncia a su trabajo y se viene
con la esperanza de que quiere pagar a
1500 pesos mínimos semanales a él no y
obviamente eso se dice fácil pero cuando
empieza a ver todo lo que involucra a
levantar un negocio empieza a ver la luz
la renta yo tengo que incluso cambiar
las las zonas eléctricas con la cf
porque no me alcanzaban los
transformadores no para lo que estábamos
haciendo y pues de repente en 1517 hacía
un poquito complicado no de pagar a sus
trabajadores y al punto de que la clase
que historia no de que todos estarían
siempre más dinero que yo al mundo de
que yo ni coche traía no de nada de nada
y todos mis trabajadores así como me
decían patrón yo les diga me leo no sé
quién le ubica ahora te llevamos ya
lléveme la central porque puesto como me
regreso no porque me tiene que regresar
a tiempo acá a morelia desde esa
comunidad empieza a hacer las cosas y
nos emocionamos mucho porque en un cabo
de nueve meses abrimos un negocio
casi haciendo por cien la cantidad que
ganaba el señor al mes entonces dijimos
guau lo logramos conectamos a una
pequeña comunidad con un negocio
manufacturero con el centro del país
bunker eta específicamente con la zona
del marqués querétaro que les agradezco
porque empezamos a hacer una buena
comunidad una buena dinámica con esta
gente con estos empresarios de allá que
le dieron la oportunidad a una comunidad
originaria a mitad de acta y es difícil
no porque pues luego no confían de que
tengan la cultura llegue a hacer
industria o la disciplina porque se
escucha fácil de que digan hacer un
negocio pero estar ocho horas matando
está haciendo un producto todos los días
durante un año es complejo y es algo que
tenemos que ir trabajando también aquí
en ese estado que tiene un chorro de
gente trabajador pero bueno regresando
un poquito al tema nos emocionamos las
deudas empezaban a decrecer 2500 ya no
nos preocupaba en gracias a dios
obviamente después de un sinfín de
clases que hasta lloramos en él a la
mitad del proceso porque me decían no va
a salir este negocio no encontramos
compradores y ya se imaginan todos los
que viven
a los nuevos chicos y grandes vivimos
exactamente lo mismo y fuimos viendo la
manera que se cristalizan y precisamente
apenas aquí inicia el motivo de estar
porque justamente en el momento en el
que mejor nos estaba yendo pp recibe una
llamada y posteriormente la visita de
unas personas que a punta de arma nos
buscaron pedir el cobro de piso porque
ya éramos una empresa que se veía que
era en persona entonces llegaron y este
chavo que les digo que por motivos de
seguridad le pongo de abril dijo yo me
encargo no sea muy envalentonado propio
de la edad él tenía y que creemos que
nos podemos comer al mundo sin embargo
edwards pero si tenemos que tener mucho
mucho mucho cuidado mucha discreción pp
me dice yo lo voy a resolver y este
chavo empieza a moverse de un modo u
otro
y logra concretar un acuerdo donde
íbamos a pagar cinco mil pesos mensuales
a este grupo que no estaba pidiendo el
cobro no la extorsión del municipio
obviamente en ese momento dicen que el
que no ha vivido una guerra se emociona
tanto está viviendo uno y el que ya la
vivió jamás en la vida se volverá a
meter a bueno pues yo me sentía muy
emocionado porque llevan activistas y yo
dije oigan tengo un problema que es la
crisis de inseguridad por primera vez lo
voy a ver y voy a tratar de resolver yo
no imaginaba que era un problema que
tenía que ver con la vida con la
seguridad de personas y con la
existencia de negocios que le dieran a
otra gente
nos cobran cinco mil pesos mensuales
posteriormente a los tres meses nos
cobran ocho mil pesos mensuales a los
seis meses nos ponen 80 mil pesos
mensuales y cuando ya estamos terminando
el segundo año negocios están parado 300
mil pesos mensuales de cobradores en la
ciudad donde yo estaba se convierte en
un completo desorden la señora que
adelante me vendía gorditas le cobraba
una cuota de 500 pesos ya le están por
el puente 50 mil y al de la papelería de
80 mil no y si no se las pagaba se
pueden incendiar el negocio entonces yo
me que muy preocupado porque dije esto
es más grande de lo que yo pensaba y
está más feo de lo que yo pensaba porque
cuando mejoran los 300 mil pesos me
secuestren a dos trabajadores y estos
dos trabajadores me dijeron si los
quieres ver a pagarnos y ven aquí a
donde están bueno pues hoy en capucha
llegó al lugar los pagos y cuando los
pagos me agarran la cabeza
me llevo a los trabajadores y siento
algo en ese momento cuando estaba ahí en
esa zona y digo este sentimiento ya lo
he sentido y no solamente tiene que ver
con ellos o sea es un sentimiento de
cuando tienes poder muchas veces la
gente te lo hace ver que tiene poder de
una manera negativa y se siente en la
política se siente en el empresariado se
siente en el crimen organizado y en
diferentes zonas que pues de cierta
manera somos culpables de crea una
cultura de miedo o una cultura de
privilegios y que tú quieras hacer
sentir que tienes un privilegio por
encima de los demás y es algo que como
generación tenemos que acabar tenemos
que tener la generación más humana de
darnos cuenta que las cosas que nos unen
son más que las que nos dividen y que al
final de cuentas todos queremos lo mismo
porque es el cobro de piso para que era
para que alguno de ellos tuviera tener
para los pañales de su bebé al final de
cuentas para pagar la enfermedad la mamá
porque así como los trabajadores estaban
conmigo querían tener mejor futuro
ellos también aunque se nos haga un
poquito difícil a veces poder ver esta
circunstancia terminó esto veo la manera
de resolver este problema porque
obviamente me estaba intimidando de ser
yo sólo contra todo lógica porque aparte
posiblemente a dios estamos jóvenes y a
veces hacemos cosas que no que si a mí
me salió bien no quiero decir que esa
sea la solución
a tocar a la puerta más empresarios y
les dijo a gas no podemos permitir esto
prosiga pero no en una guerra sino en
paz porque la única manera que los
negocios en adelante es cuando hay un
muro o algo que sea jurídico una
protección jurídica y que tienes dinero
no o sea entonces si hay dinero y en la
protección jurídica y estado de derecho
tienes lana puede seguir adelante y
puedes comprar tratar de ver qué hacer
no y así todos los amos aquí no salió
adelante porque hemos tenido momentos de
paz donde hagamos para salir y seguir
creciendo a veces no lo gastamos menos
en drogas pero cualquiera de las dos ahí
andamos no dicho estamos echándole ganas
y esto y aprendemos acá lo malo es de
que no te dejaban ahorrar porque pues
obviamente estas personas no se fijaban
en si te salía el equilibrio a la hora
de tener tus cuentas al final del mes y
pues obviamente no les importaba y lo
entiendo eso lo entiendo porque es un
fenómeno que no nada más son de ellos es
un fenómeno que todos somos parte de que
se haya causado y haya existido porque
tuvimos una generación previa que sólo
se encargaba de producir sin preocuparse
por las demás personas
llegando a este punto de toque más
empresarios vimos la manera de
solucionarlo yo dije por medio de la
policía dijeron que la policía no le
pagaban entonces solamente tenemos
actualizas en el municipio y con el
ejército me decían que el ejército
responde a las órdenes del presidente y
lamentablemente como iba a saber si ese
grupo no estaba con él en el gobierno y
por otro lado dije entonces que abusa
pues no tengo nada más a toda la gente
que vivimos en la comunidad no sé a
veces el sentido común es el menos común
de los sentidos y yo dije pues bueno
pues para la gente de la comunidad no
nos organizamos creamos una organización
comunitaria para poner dinero le pagamos
a los policías y de tener seis policías
en la comunidad tuvimos 30 policías
entre todos los empresarios empezamos a
cooperar 30 policías que la primera
circunstancia en la primera reunión que
tuvimos fue oigan qué hacemos con esos
policías si yo tengo un problema a mí no
me van a cobrar verdad y yo les dije no
estos policías son para que a cualquiera
que hagamos un acto que esté en contra
de la ley a todos nos lleguen incluso a
los que les estamos cooperando para que
estén aquí y pues fue muy difícil
les digo porque estamos acostumbrados
escrutar el privilegio pero se logró y
la gente dijo tiene razón
esta ley nos conviene a todos porque tú
tienes una hija y si con esa hija se
profesa alguien un maizal policía
ahí está el ministerio público más tú
tienes un negocio si alguien te los
radio además tienes alguien que probar y
se empezaron a dar cuenta que el estado
derecho nos convenía esto en una
población de 80 mil personas para
declarar nos empezamos a reunir y desde
aproximadamente un año
no tenemos obra oro de cuota de piso y
todo lo que hemos dicho nosotros ha sido
no queremos que haya ninguna
circunstancia negativa ni con el crimen
organizado ni con el gobierno ni con los
empresarios lo que queremos es paz para
seguir adelante porque sabemos que somos
fregones los mexicanos pero necesitamos
un tiempo para hacerlo y justamente ahí
prácticamente les quería enseñar una
frase que fue con la que cerramos un día
de la organización y les dije nosotros
armamos a los policías y los financiamos
para que tuviéramos seguridad en el
municipio nos instruimos en leyes para
que se dan cuenta que su deber no era
hacer pompa de nadie o de verdad para
con méxico fuimos viendo la manera de
tener minutos para conversar para que no
viera balazos porque la verdadera
revolución en este país sería comenzar
justamente hace
y comenzará a conversar con diferentes
personas que no piensen igual que tienen
diferentes vidas y que han vivido
diferentes circunstancias
nolan o atacarnos tener esa paz esa paz
aquí en michoacán nos costó en el cámara
estos lugares si alguna vez les pasa
algo por el estilo
especialmente arm es organización
comunitaria hablen con los empresarios
de la zona y traten de encontrar la
manera de por medio de algo organizado
salir adelante méxico necesitas ico
necesita ese tiempito de poder salir
adelante porque además como bien lo
decían ahorita en el comienzo de startup
hoy estamos en un mundo globalizado y no
estamos compitiendo con el vecino de la
esquina estamos compitiendo con empresas
que están en singapur con empresas están
en japón y si nosotros los mexicanos
echamos la mano para poder salir
adelante o en ellos es que no va a serlo
aquí estamos y pues espero les haya
gustado esta primera intervención